I'm going to a Renaissance festival and
a full suit of screen accurate
stormtrooper armor and I only have three
hours to accomplish three tasks get into
the Renaissance Festival even if I have
to sneak my way in find the king and
queen of the festival accomplish
whatever Quest they give me and do it
all in under three hours but first we
have to get into the festival I don't
know if anyone else has ever done this
before so it's a bit scary
okay that was easy I was finally pointed
in the exact right direction to find the
king and queen I wouldn't feel but I
literally can't yes I see that look we
should ask them to join our military oh
how good is your aim I won't be able to
hit anything okay all right
scoundrel amongst our court the Pirates
King I would look for him and I thought
that is your command my queen it is
[Music]